[Music]
since its release on Tuesday Prince
Harry's revealing and controversial
Memoir has jumped to the top of several
bestseller lists spare has been making
headlines as the 38-year-old former
senior member of the British royal
family Bears all the latest interview
with Harry airs tonight on CBS and this
morning Harry himself reads excerpts
from his book and provides more of the
surprising Recollections that have
garnered the world's attention
I love my father I love my brother I
love my family I always do nothing of
what I've done in this book or otherwise
has ever been to any intention to harm
them or hurt them in his debut Memoir
Prince Harry shares a glimpse into his
most private relationships including
with his brother Prince William and
father King Charles your two criticism
of your dad really I would say
summarizing kind of intimacy and
communication problems he's not there
for you as frequently or in quite the
way you want
he'd always given an air of being not
quite ready for Parenthood the
responsibilities the patience the time
even he though a proud man would have
admitted as much
but single Parenthood
power was never made for that
to be fair he tried
no topic seems off limits as he reads a
vivid description of a physical
altercation between he and Prince
William it all happened so fast so very
fast
he grabbed me by the collar ripping my
necklace and he knocked me to the floor
I landed on the dog's ball which cracked
under my back the pieces cutting into me
I lay there for a moment dazed and got
to my feet and told him to get out
come on hit me you'll feel better if you
hit me
do what
come on we always used to fight you'll
feel better if you hit me
no
only you'll feel better if I hit you
please just leave
he left the kitchen but he didn't leave
not caught
he was in the sitting room I could tell
I stayed in the kitchen
two minutes passed two long minutes he
came back looking regretful and
apologized he walked to the front door
this time I followed
before leaving he turned and called back
you don't need to tell Meg about this
you mean that you attacked me I didn't
attack you Harold
fine I won't tell her his transparency
shows a side of the royal family many
have not seen they're going to be
sitting there reeling at this level of
personal disclosure aren't they and that
and that will make some people angry
though we have to be honest about that
of course some people will say you have
railed against invasions of your privacy
all your life but they the accusation
will be here are you invading the
privacy of your most nearest and dearest
without permission that'll be the
accusation that'll be the accusation
from the people that don't understand or
haven't or don't want to believe that my
family have been briefing the press
solidly for well over a decade
so
I'm sorry that me owning my story and
being able to tell my own story is
upsetting to some people
but I have to rely on the truth despite
it all Prince Harry remains hopeful for
reconciliation I think there's probably
a lot of people who after watching the
documentary and reading the book will go
how could you ever forgive your family
for what they've done
people have already said that to me and
I said forgiveness is 100 a possibility
because I would like to get my father
back I would like to have my brother
back at the moment I don't recognize
them as much as they probably don't
recognize me
and you can see all of the Prince Harry
interview tonight at 8 7 Central right
here on CBS where you can stream it on
Paramount plus beginning tomorrow
I I I I I I don't even know what to say
when you sit and you watch him explain
the things that he explains he lived
through or claims to have lived through
he has a very believable air about him
it just I take it in with everything
else we know the crown I mean even the
fictionalized version of what we watch
and what we see it plays into his
narrative it's been fascinating to watch
all of it I can't get enough I admit it
I'll be watching yeah and this is him
reading from the book yeah yeah